the seamless chess club's YouTube
channel at chess club's classic center
of st. Louis it's so enormous ly popular
is all the replays that we do for these
made for tournaments but in addition to
that hundreds of lessons from
grandmasters who come here to be grand
mastering residents and the success has
went out with tons of subscribers we got
over a hundred thousand subscribers in
over 31 million views and usually was
actually recognized a success and we
have a presentation for you at that
along with a Ben Simon who works here
for the Chess Club brilliant hello
youtube world Ben Simon here alongside
deputy arbiter for the Sinquefield Cup
and the most entertaining man in chess
you asked for him he's back it's Mike
comer and we have a box and what's
inside this box from that big tech giant
Google is pretty cool let me show you
what it is it's for our YouTube channel
we have received a beautiful look at
this note there's a lot of stuff in that
note an stl chess club silver play
button isn't this beautiful this play
button right here is for Mike comer it's
for Jonathan and Isaac France Julian
Poli ko every grandmaster and other
title player who's ever lectured here at
the club and for anyone who's ever
enjoyed a lecture we want to thank you
for 100,000 subscribers and this is
going right on the wall here at the
front of the chess club cutie pie we're
coming for you all right that's that's
an amazing fact I think at some point
that's going to be shown in the museum
you know I have a lot of friends and
students who love the Chess Club and
Scholastic Center in st. Louis is
YouTube channel and ask it's free so
sometimes I don't even go write about
that I'm getting all these lessons and
it's totally for you what you can do you
can make a donation to the st. Louis
chess club you can become a member of
the world chess all the fame in the st.
Louis chess club you can go to Q
boutique and buy present products that
you buy from Cuba teak or like from the
club we have sets clocks board books all
for sale it's a mean things that you
would buy anyway let's buy them from us
and it really shows your appreciation
and motivate some the guys led by a Ben
Simon and Hummer
to continue making the channel even
better and veteran know there's some
really special merchandise there as well
like you can buy the pins that we're
wearing the mugs that were drinking
coffee much needed when there's a 7 hour
games yes and there's also signed boards
that's going to cost you a little bit
more money but for less than $200 you
can get a single cup roll-aboard
signed by magnus carlsen Fabiano karana
and all the players in the tournament
nice nice and it's my favorite charity
along with my life event were members of
the Kisa chess club Maurice and I have
donated donated as well this is such a
wonderful cause and I'm taking some of
the credits for all those billions of
views because I'm one of the lecturers I
know you guys okay we all get credit we
all get a pat on the back and that award
is for all of us who work here